مشاهير وسيم يموتون واحدا تلو الاخر فقدت
اوبرا بيكين مغنيه سوبرانو المعروفه شوقا
التي توفيت فجاه وهي في الاربعين من عمرها
وقبل عده ايام توفي لاعب كره القدم منذ
اودي الذي يبلغ من العمر 37 عاما كما توفي
المخرج بونج بونج وهو في الرابعه والخمسين
من عمره
توفي زوجي العزيز ونشون
ظهر يوم الاحد والعشرين من ديسمبر عام
2022 بسبب المرض
العديد من الصينيين يعتقدون ان السبب وراء
هذه الوفيات هو فيروس كروم اما سلطاته
الصحيه الصينيه فهي تقول ان عدد الوفيات
من جراء الكرونه لا يتعدى ال 20 منذ انهاء
القيود الخاصه بالفيروس في شهر ديسمبر
الماضي
الارقام الحقيقيه ثانيا لتفادي الاعلان عن
عدد كبير من الوفيات لا يؤخذ في الاعتبار
غير الاشخاص الذين ماتوا مباشره جراء
الكمبيوتر
في صفوف الاولى لست الوحيده التي تشكك في
صحتها اخرى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]